[Music]
hello I'm Chris and I'm Emily and I'm
here to see if I can become best friends
with anyone on the street we'll only
have five minutes to get to know each
other using questions from this deck of
cars before we go head to head in a
trivia challenge I'm doing this because
the pandemic has just eliminated my
social abilities and we need to rebuild
I
know I
could anyone like I could move to anyone
and become besties all right so I have
about five minutes to find my new best
friend on the street let's go
foreign
no okay excuse me
[Music]
sorry to bother you I'm just looking for
someone who's going to take five minutes
to try and become best friends with me
on the street
okay I understand I appreciate it though
thank you you don't have five minutes to
try and become best friends with me on
the spot
okay I appreciate that I'll take that do
you have five minutes to try and become
best friends with me right now
sure I've only got a few minutes oh yes
okay
excuse me do you want to be best friends
sure okay cool
I did it
I'm Emily oh my God wait I think
where'd you get it the Dr does Dominican
Republic I'm Dominican shut up oh my God
I know we are instantly best friends
Arthur we have about 30 questions in
only five minutes mathematically it's
gonna be a little tight but we need to
get to know each other okay all right
ready what is your favorite movie
everything everywhere all at once mine
is part and Prejudice what is your
middle name Adams Adams Russell Adams
Russell that should be easy to remember
right we'll see we're killing we're
moving here we go do you have any
siblings in what are their names Karen
Mark Sandy Karen Mark Sandy Kirsten
younger sister Kirsten what is your most
impressive skill aerial arts I can sing
a word okay
Karen what were your name
I won't let myself forget that how are
we doing on time I feel like I'm going
too slow I'm going to run out of time
what is your most annoying habit I don't
know this question is kind of weird
next
what is your middle name Rose Carmen
okay oh my God I'm not moving fast
enough uh what is your favorite band
artist slash musician I'll go Elvis for
just a favorite uh I love it let's
double up let's double up this isn't
cheating we're just already excuse me
very aligned what is your biggest goal
in life
to win an Oscar wait minus win an
Academy Award hey see you there see you
there best friend okay what do you do to
get rid of stress sex
it's a good answer that's a great answer
my family watching maybe I agree uh
uh the PG answer is watch TV January
20th okay so your birthday's coming
generation mine is April 7th April 7th
yeah my most impressive skill playing
drums okay yeah there you go
okay what is your favorite oh I think I
answered everything
what was your favorite movie proud and
Prejudice Pride and Prejudice uh
everything everywhere all at once yes
best friends
all right I think we have a few more
here
um
we barely got to know each other I have
uh
I trust that we were just like in sync
zoning it yeah it doesn't matter
irrelevant we're gonna nail this okay
let's do it
[Music]
wasn't
[Music]
uh if you know you know do you know are
you guessing no I know
I also know Brown
hey good job having brown eyes brown
eyes uh
uh January 5th wow
April 7 and I'm an Aries very
interesting yeah two to two she puts up
her fists I don't know I'm hearing a lot
of excuse excuses
drums I'm a drummer
technically oh so you don't think drums
are interesting okay aerial arts aerial
arts three to two no word at all yeah
oh
I'm trying to think of what I said
what if I don't remember but I know I
agreed with Arthur whatever it was
doesn't sound like it's a point leaving
New York yes an airplane I don't know if
I would count that one spiders
oh my God 100 confident in my bestie
loser excuse me excuse me uh this is as
good as we're gonna get three siblings
two sisters one brother
Karen Mark Sandy I got two and points
shaking their head off camera I have a
sister named Kirsten and she only had to
memorize one his middle name that's what
you want obviously I know middle name's
middle name my middle name is Russell so
close Andy so close Razor's Edge Carmen
oh
man we're ahead by Five Points ten yeah
yeah it's like I think it's much closer
it's much closer the math is not math
win or lose what we've built is so much
more important than this game I just
want to let that go on record so true oh
dude hold on
a very long year 3 000. I did the far
future the year
2700. that is not only 300 that's that's
enough they ever take 300 years the
Golden Age of Hollywood
Golden Era pretty pretty broad pretty
broad yeah I mean
yeah give or take 300 years yeah that's
fine that's golden age that's nothing of
the universe oh my God
yeah
show us the shoe old man Reeboks
dress shoes
adorable adorable oh oh I want to know
what's going on over here because it's
bordering on uh suspicious my dog Bella
oh yeah
my sister Kirsten with the heart wow
there's like so easy six four I'm
guessing somewhere around six foot four
oh
what an insane question to get a spot on
five three oh wow
[Applause]
I feel like I disappointed you in some
moments there though you could never
disappoint me that means right here you
can't lose if you've got a best friend
now we're not friends anymore
thanks for this video we will never be
friends ever
[Music]